قرر الجيش الاسرائيلي اغلاق المجال الجوي
المدني على مسافه سته كيلومترات من الحدود
اللبنانيه والسوريه شمال اسرائيل 6
كيلومترات من الحدود مع قطاع غزه وافادت
القناه الحاديه عشره الاسرائيليه انه تم
توزيع رساله بهذا الخصوص لسلطات المطارات
على ان يبقى الحظر ساريا حتى الساعه
السابعه والنصف من مسائل احد المقبله
معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره ناصر الحسين
ناصر اهلا بك اذا هذه الاجراءات الجديده
التي تتخذ من قبل اسرائيل تاتي في اي سياق
هذه الاجراءات مفترجه لحد ما نعم هناك كما
هو معروف التوتر في هذه المنطقه منذ
الاعتداءات في الاقصى وما تبعها من من
سلسله عنف من صواري القادمه من قطاع غزه
او من لبنان كان ذلك متوقعا على مستوى
كافه
القرارات التي اتخذت السلطات الاسرائيليه
من حيث القرارات التي تهم داخل الاسرائيلي
لكن الان ونحن نرى ان اسرائيل تقرر الان
وضع نوع من الحزام الامني او الخطا او
حزام السلامه الجوي حول اراضي اسرائيل
فاننا ولا شك امام ولا شكل موقع او موقع
امني جديد لم يعلن بعد عن سحورها القرار
الاسرائيلي يعني الان ان الاجواء
الاسرائيليه ستخلو من اي طيران مدني يمكن
الان ان نتخيل سعه هذا القرار الاسرائيلي
على بعد سته كيلومترات من الاجواء
الاسرائيليه
ومغلقه ايضا وعمليا امام المدني فوق قطاع
غزه
الاسرائيلي فوق شمال اسرائيل ايضا باتجاه
العمق الاسرائيلي اتجاه تل ابيب والقدس
والعمق الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذا النوع من
الحزام الامني الجويه الذي تسعى اسرائيل
من خلاله الى حمايه نفسها من اي تحرك
للاعداء وهنا القصد تلك الصواريخ القادمه
من الشمال من الجهه اللبنانيه او من
الجنوب الغربي من غزه هذا واضح جدا ان
السلطات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تتوقع مثل
هذا السيناريو الى يوم الاحد المقبل طالما
ظل هذا القرار ثانيا والسياق العام وهو ان
الان يكثر الحديد داخل اسرائيل من معلقين
او السياسيين عن احتمالات حرب ما في
المستقبل القريب بضعه حال اليوم دفع ان
تكون هناك اي نيه للحرب معنى التقليدي
للكلمه ولكنه اكد ايضا اسرائيل مستعده
وبالتالي هذا القرار انما يعزز تلك
الاستعدادات الاسرائيليه التي بدات اصلا
منذ حادثه الاعتداءات
مع الجانب الفلسطيني
من غزه من طرف
بهذا شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلة جزيلا ناصر
الحسيني كنت معنا من القدس